i actually have a philosophy here do you
want to hear how i've traveled the world
gone to the best places in the world
eating the best foods partied harder
than maybe anybody for under a thousand
dollars whoa do you want to hear this
travel advisors hate him yeah you want
to hear this here's something so i
talked about nobody likes a leech paying
your fair share let me give you a little
piece of advice here
so when i was broke i had a buddy that
um
was doing pretty well it was actually a
stock broker his name was steve i said
steve bro i'm struggling right now i'm
24 years old you know you're my buddy i
got no place to live right now you know
i can i guess move in with my mom i'm
not trying to do all that let me crash
your house and in return i'll clean the
house and i'll pay the utilities okay so
i was living in a dope house this is my
buddy i cleaned the house 24 years old
i'm basically like a male maid
right and i'm paying the utility bills
he's like all right that's cool i got a
big house like i live all alone cool you
know he was doing really well
and then that basically realized that
you know you can do things and things
that don't have to be equal i'll give
you a couple examples one of my best
friends his name is keith he's one of
the biggest hospitality nightlife guys
in miami you go out with this guy he
takes care of everything he pays the
bills he takes care of the bottles he
takes care of the meal
but when it's time to leave a tip for
the server i will always pay the tip
this is when i was struggling right yeah
still to this day if we go out he owns
the club so it's not like he's going to
hit us up to pay this club
when the bill comes he signs his check i
will always give 100 bucks to the server
boom thank you so he's thinking my man
sells bro thank you buddy because nobody
likes a leech a couple other examples
one time i was with my girl
we went on a couples trip and a wealthy
wealthy friend of ours he's from greece
and uh he paid for a ridiculous house in
greece ridiculous he's like look i'm
from greece you come with me you stay at
the house
obviously we had to pay for our plane
tickets so we got there
and
you know we get there i go look i'm
stacking the fridge stock in the fridge
i'm going to go out i spent 500 bucks
drinks
food you know snacks whatever i will
stock the fridge okay so i'm traveling
the world i'm partying how much have i
spent support 500 another 100 another
100. here's another example
i go with pbd
with pat to eat all the time pat always
picks up the tab it's not even a
question
pat always valets he always puts his car
up front and i learned very quickly
he doesn't necessarily have cash every
time i go out to pat with pat i pay 20
bucks for the valet it's like an inside
joke i go pat you take care of dinner
yeah i'm taking care of valet and it's
like it's almost like
assumed at this point adam you want to
take care of it i got it it's tradition
now tradition he's taking care of a 300
meal i got the 20 valet okay
we went to we flew in a private jet
to vegas yeah right we get out of the
jet we must have missed that text by the
way what's that must have not gotten
that text yeah you didn't get that text
it was an email we flew back from vegas
you know there was a probably 10 of us
on the on the jet me
pat mario caroline kai
pat's dad leo a handful of people it was
awesome
um
we get off the plane he goes hey you
want to go give 100 bucks to the um
to the the hostess you know the server
on the play it was one lady i go yeah
done i just flew private 100 bucks so
what's my point nobody likes a leech and
pay your fair share someone who's a
multi-multi-millionaire or is way better
than you isn't expecting you to split it
with you but they don't want to feel
like they're just paying for everything
and you're just sitting there doing
nothing so whether it's pat paying 20
bucks for valet whether it's giving 100
bucks to the server on the plane or the
hostess
the flight attendant what do you call it
flight attendant one person it's one
person she was doing everything i gave
her a hundred bucks no problem so the
point is i've tried flipping i've flown
on private jets
i've partied at the best clubs in south
beach i've been to
all over the world greece stayed at
amazing places stayed for free i've
lived with buddies but i've always
thrown in i've always
it works both ways by the way so i have
a buddy of mine named tj he doesn't make
that much money so every time he comes
over we hang out i'll buy dinner we'll
go out whatever it is he will always
bring me a cigar or always bring like a
12 pack of beer so he spends 15 20 bucks
that way i'm like yo thanks bro i
appreciate it so the point is there's
levels there's going to be levels above
you
yeah and there's going to be levels
below you but nobody likes a leech a
leech you can't always keep up
financially with everyone but you could
always throw in you could always throw
in a 20 or 100 whatever it is so john
says give and you shall receive given
you shall receive people like saying you
know what i like rolling sauce because
you know we go out he takes care of the
waitress every time ppd i go i roll we
have dinner with adam obviously business
dinner he takes care of valet thanks bro
appreciate it it's the little things
that they remember okay so you know
maybe someone does something nice for
you send them a gift spend 50 bucks on a
gift whatever it is so here's my advice
let me this wasn't something that i was
going to like this was a whole segment
but this just kind of came to my mind
number one provide value
okay these this is my advice
on how to roll with the bosses and
basically experience the world for
basically under a thousand bucks number
one provide value whether that's
friendship whether that's just they they
enjoy your company whether that's you
you do business together and they just
want your uh your mindset whatever it is
provide value valuetainment number two
throw it down don't be a leech then
number three
pay it forward like our friend said give
and you shall receive good things will
happen to you nobody likes a leech is
money all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken